a lot more than they do now I think that
a great problem in recognizing the peril
of the living environment one that
ultimately affects our lives is
ignorance most people including
political leaders have no real idea of
what it is to start with how much there
is and why it's important to protect it
and also how fast it's disappearing I
have a little sort of but summary
expression about that that I like to
make which is that if we protect the
living environment that's the rest of
life you know a variety of it then we
will automatically protect the physical
environment has a you know the base the
physical and chemical material based on
which it exists because we have to do
that in order to save the living
environment but if we only say the
physical environment purify our water
control our use of irreplaceable
resources and so on fine enough food to
feed everybody if we only do that then
and we don't pay attention to the living
environment then eventually we're going
to lose both
you